hello everybody of pi data global 2020
my name is alexander
and i'm here to present my work cardinal
a matrix based active learning framework
uh first small word about my company so
i'm working at the daiku
which provides a data science platform
to democratize access to data
and artificial intelligence we have more
than 400 employees across the globe
we're working with many industries and
as you can see on the left we like to
have
uh chill meetings on the favorites of
our office but i
assure you that if you want to join us
we also have proper tail
and tables uh since we are not able to
meet
you see here my full picture i'm working
at
a team called the lab inside that aku
which aims at working on applied
research
uh to contribute to research and try to
find applications
to be integrated uh in our tool so in my
case
active learning uh
so what i'm going to talk about going to
talk about active learning first
a small introduction then i will tell
you why we need we believe that we need
metrics and then i will introduce you
cardinal
our python package let's go
first what is active learning and when
do we use it so activating it's an
experimental framework that allows to
speed up
labeling and reduce the cost uh to reach
the best accuracy of the model
it's typically used when you have a lot
of data that is not labeled and you need
to label it to start a task
you cannot label everything or if you
just want to speed up the process
most typical examples are medical
imaging because hiring a radiologist to
label data is very costly
you can have classification for diabetic
retinopathy for example
or detecting malignant cancer cells in
histological data
you also have named entity recognition
so here you have prodigy
an interface over the very famous spacey
model from facebook
uh you can see that active learning can
help
labeling by pre-labeling some samples
that are already there
and the best is a model the less the
annotator
has to work to do so that's how
active learning works let's look at the
workflow first we get the data
then we have a step that is proper to
activate which is create selection so a
query is a sample that we want to send
to an annotator
uh to be labeled obviously uh nowadays
we
training a model is very costly so we
usually pick a batch
of this sample 100 and send them to
several annotators
once we've done that we get labeled
sample that we use to train our model
here we take a decision either we have
no object budget
left or the model is good enough so we
ship to production
or we can label more in that case we
will examine the samples
that are remaining and the model to be
able to select a new batch of queries
and we loop again until we have
exhausted the budget or reached
a given accuracy goal
so uh to for us to be all on the same
level about active learning i will
present the basics
uh first the intuition so on the left
you can see the endness data set which
is a very famous one it's a tsne
representation
of course in active running we would
have no label so the first things to do
is to look at the most representative
samples
this will be our first uh queries
and for that we can look at a density or
a user clustering method to find the one
that are
the most typical in the space this is
called representativeness
uh once we have trained the model we
look at informativeness what are the
samples that bring the most information
to the model and for that we look at the
one that are along
decision boundaries in usual here in the
mnist we can look at nine that looks
like seven it's very typical
but actually i told you that we select a
batch of subjects a batch of samples
sorry
and we may not want to send only nine
and seven to our annotators so sometimes
we
also want to optimize for diversity
meaning we will try to
sample the space and look at samples
that are
scattered all around so those are the
three
main criteria that are optimized by all
active learning methods
although representativeness and
diversity since they are based on
distance between samples similarity
dis similarity matrix they are usually
optimized together
so let's go back to the base the
the the paper that put the basics of
learning uh written by settles in 2009
so in that paper it defines the most
basic uncertainty based method so the
method that are
based on the prediction of the model on
the left you see a table with four
classes abcd each row
is the probability prediction for a
given sample so we have three samples
and what we are looking to see now is
which is the sample that is the most
informative for the model so only
informativeness
one first method is to look at the one
with the higher uncertainty
so the lowest top class classification
probability
in that case it would be the first one
it has 0.4 which is the lowest top
probability among all samples
we can take the intuition of the seven
and nine that look like
each other and say okay that's the
difference between the two classes that
is important
in that case we look at the margin this
is exactly that
the difference between the two top
methods in that case we would select the
second
sample or we can say all the values
are useful and in that case we take the
very classical entropy measure
and in that case we would select the
third row so i just have a
hand pick this value to obtain this
result but
what i wanted to show you is that even
the most basic method on a very simple
cases can
disagree with each other
and now we'll take a look at more
advanced method just to
again build the intuition so here we
have we start with the setting on the
left we have selected
we have two labels so from random points
we build up a decision boundary and we
optimize for informativeness so we look
at the at the sample that are the
closest to this boundary
we end up with the situation on the
right and you see what happened there is
that we optimize for
informativeness uncertainty and we
totally ignore this
enable cluster on the top left so what
lee has proposed is to train another
classifier
for just for the sake of selecting the
queries and this one is attracted to
unlabeled samples
and it is implemented by adding in the
training set of the svm
these unlabeled samples with the both
labels uh
since it's impossible to solve the
decision boundary will
uh obviously be attracted to this set
and by doing that we obtain a better
model in the iteration just after so
that's the interest of mixing them
we can also put all them together in one
big minimization problem
uh that's what is proposed by you in
2015. i will not go through all
the equation what you have to remember
is just that we
in this uh in this method we minimize
the similarity between query samples
so we do not want the queries to look
like each other it's diversity
we minimize the similarity between the
queries and the label sample
so we want to go far away from what we
have already labeled
and we want to maximize the similarity
between the queries and the end label
so then we will be attracted to a big
then a big cluster of
with high density so and you put all of
that in one
immunization problem and that's one way
again to uh
to mix all of them together i presented
this method because i want to look at
the results actually
for the key both of them have worked on
the same data set which is called
australia
come from uci and we see clearly that
you
2015 in the top left is clearly the best
method
by far what's interesting actually it's
another method called choir
in both of these results we see that
choir is not better than uncertainty not
better than random actually of this map
all this method
perform approximately the same so we can
look back
at the choir paper and what choir in
their paper
one has proven is that they are better
than these methods
not much better than random but still a
bit and actually much better than
uncertainty which has a very bad score
and this is not what we find in the
other ones so
it's very uh troubling to see to see
those results and
we wonder how to choose the best method
actually in a series of paper
cod could prove that it can be hard to
compare active learning experiments
in particular in the bottom left he has
reproduced the experimental
setting that most people use in this
paper which is five-fold
cross-validation and he has shown that
by changing the seed we obtain very
different results
so it may not be enough and if you if
you repeat this experiment you obtain
what you see on the right
and you see that the conclusion that
most other people have reached in other
domains
confidence interval matters so that's
one thing we can say
we also try experiments on this
on this data set and what we found out
is that what we call easy task
meaning task on which the selection of
the model doesn't really matter all of
them perform very well with a small
number of samples
well in that case it's very hard to get
a winner because they all get very good
performances
very fast uh so that's what we show on
on the right you can see one example on
one that i set and on the left
uh you see comparison that we have made
so on easy task we see that random and
k-means
uh that i will talk about later are bad
but among the best one is how to say
whereas on the hard task we are able to
find a winner
so that was our conclusion but yet
another researcher said even on other
tasks it's not that easy so on the left
you can see a paper called corset
uh in their paper uh the researchers
showed that they are far better than
uncertainty in random
and actually on the right same data set
different model
we see that the proposed method is
better but they compare to corset
which has exactly the same score as
uncertainty
so it's hard to say okay it's very hard
to see
what is happening and the problem is
that when you're an industrial
practitioner you have a data set that
nobody
has ever worked on so you can compare it
to existing but it's on
and plus it's a one-shot experiment so
the thing you cannot
allow to happen is to be worse than
random and we've seen actually that some
of them
are worse than random in some cases so
how do i choose my method
and more importantly how do i say that
i'm not doing worse than rather
for that we introduced some matrix so
here you'll see that we do not have the
all the answers but we're
starting to work on that and we already
have some
some outcomes from our study so first
before
getting to be any metric we need to know
okay what are we evaluating
uh on the right you see uh what we
usually see in
active learning papers meaning a curve
that is increasing with the number of
iterations
what most people do is just visual
inspection of the paper
trying to find patterns like how do they
behave in the end
is there a way in a moment in the
experiment where one is better than the
other and this one
can be at the beginning so they make
interpretation like that
other prefer to set a really a fixed
point in time where they compare them or
some of them just look at the area under
the accuracy curve for example that's
what
we have decided to do to perform on the
test that i've shown you
the problem we have is how do we measure
that in real life because obviously it's
a result setting
is there a way to get the same the same
information
in a real experiment that we are doing
right now
so we have a label set
it's small we have done it manually but
it exists
so we can say okay let's run classical
cross validation
the problem is that this set is small
this set will grow with time
making the the problem more complex so
the accuracy inside this set may
actually decrease over time or increase
it's very hard to say
and the problem is that if we want to
use this label set to evaluate the
performance of the query strategy we
cannot
because it is biased by the query
strategy that i selected the samples we
wanted to put into
so one query strategy could really
explore
a small part of the space we will never
know because we only look at the label
samples
that have been selected by the query
strategy
another method is the one using research
which is okay let's take an independent
label test set
the problem is that we have a business
problem when you're an industrial
practitioner and you say okay we are
going to label a lot of samples
just for the sake of validation
obviously it brings you some information
most people would be doubtful that it's
worth the budget spent to label them
so really what we wanted to do is to get
inside from an independent unlabeled
test set when i say independent i mean
the query strategy is not able to peek
in them
so that stay completely outside of the
experiment
uh the first thing we can compute is
maybe uh
the exploration because i've talked
about it uh several times
and uh what we can look when we have
this independent test set
is the distance to the nearest neighbor
of each of the sample in the label set
the more we explore the space the more
this distance will decrease
and that's what we see here so we take a
look at the difference between each
iteration because it's strictly
decreasing
what we see is that actually it goes low
very fast
and uh it can give us can give us an
an intuition about how good we have
explored the the space and actually what
we see we have we
we had to put a log scale because we see
that after 700
uh samples labeled on ldpa we
all the method kinda go toward the same
the same score uh just a bit of a word
ldp is a data set with data from
accelerometer
from sensors that is used to determine
the position of a human being the goal
being to
detect when all people will fall when
they are at home
so we have found this set this data set
to be uh particularly complicated
in active learning and this is why we
focused on this one
in this talk and if we look at this
course
across several data sets we see that
random and k-means are the best ones
obviously because they are unsupervised
they are meant to
uh to explore so k-means is just a
k-means random data
and we take the samples closest to the
centroid so we expect them to be
really scattered across the space so
that's one thing
maybe we want to wait for it to be low
enough low enough being
we can for example select randomly some
samples
and compare to random and when we reach
a value signal to random
we can stop so that's one way
another big question is when to stop
leveling because if i save some budget
uh by uh labeling faster but i do not
trade
and do not stop at the right moment then
i will just spend the same budget
as if i didn't do active learning so one
method proposed by a game in 2010
rely on the intuition that at the
beginning of the experiment we have a
lot of
uh high uncertainty samples so the
variance is low but all the values are
high
during the training some value we gain
more certainty so we'll have
a higher variance in the uncertainty
score and in the end
all the values all the uncertainty are
very low so again we reach
a low valence state and in the top part
we see that
actually what happens in their
experiment
and we see that actually in the scores
in the end it's not worth labeling
anymore the only problem in that
seems to be in this graph that we may
have wanted to stop labeling before but
it seems to be efficient another uh
approach proposed by vlashos which is
looking at the average
of this course and what was what they
see
is that uh when you reach the uh
accuracy plateau
it seems that uh the these costs start
to uh decrease
actually that's what you see on the left
and uh based on that they created an
indicator called contradictory
information which takes the score
uh the uncertainty score of sample
divided by the
the average and all the data which gives
some indicator that decreases so again
we have some indicator
uh how to see how to use it yet but
another metric to test and finally
we have build also our own it's called
contradiction
and basically we take we look at the
independent test set
and we look at the ratio of sample for
which the prediction has changed
because it's a maximum boundary over the
uh the accuracy
so we expect it if it goes near zero it
means
okay the model is not changing decision
so you can stop labeling
whether it's good or not keeping the
same setting will not help
same if it's flat lining it may mean
that
we still have a lot of contradiction
going ongoing so the
model is uncertain but keep
keeping the same setting doesn't seem to
up so that gives you a bit of intuition
and we've seen that so here ldpa again
we see that the best methods are the
ones that have the lowest contradiction
in the end
and on the other hand the worst methods
still have a lot of contradiction
uh at the end of the of the experiment
when we run that on several data sets we
observe that actually
the correlation between the two matrix
is high uh especially when we have good
methods actually
when methods are performing well uh when
we have very bad methods
uh the contradiction is not very
informative because in this
ratio of a sample that changes some of
them may be good changes
but when you have a bad method they can
change labeling for another wrong label
but that's a way that to move on on this
subject
so what happened is that today we do not
have definitive conclusion about matrix
but we have a lot of them we've seen
that they are useful in some experiment
and we want to do that on a larger scale
and to do that we need proper software
uh
so as i said the active learning
experiments are based on the for loop
they can be very costly
particularly if you're using deep
learning so we want a package that will
make them easier to write and that will
offer uh to
us some guarantees like resume resuming
case of error and being able to replay
the experiment to ease reproducibility
on one side
and to make it easier to compute matrix
so i will go into the details
of that in the last section
first a bit of landscape of the python
botanical system around active running
so we have three main packages
all of them provide really great query
something strategies
and actually you can use them together
with cardinal
i will focus on the specificities of
each one uh quickly
so first model has a minimalistic design
it focuses on ensemble approaches where
you use several classifiers
and the voting system to select the
queries and you provide that's what's
interesting for us
an active learning object that allows
you to run experiment
with in-memory caching so you have easy
access to previous values
it doesn't bring you resuming or any
fancy feature
we have alipay that has been created in
nanjing university
it provides exclusive method along with
really a wide range
of query samplers so a lot of them are
from this lab but
you also have different different ones
from the literature
so it's really a good one if you want to
experiment and they provide a nile
experiment object that's easy experiment
with this caching so you can
uh resume an experiment that has failed
but you cannot replay
and finally we have elibact which is
more oriented for performance so i would
say the one you would use
if you are doing active learning at
scale so a lot of data
there it has compile c code so it can be
a bit difficult to install
if you do some exclusive query sampling
too like
meta active learning you know not going
to the detail doesn't provide
a lot of utilities uh noisy labeler for
uh
for some experiment but otherwise it's
up to the to the user to do most of it
so the philosophy of candidate is close
to what you can find with cyclical
we do not want to uh to integrate all
the uh research
method of the literature so we only want
to have tried and tested query
strategies and matrix
for that for all the methods we
integrate we provide
detailed examples and experiments and
obviously we want to
ease the reproducibility and metric
research by providing
a replay of experiment we also have a
human readable cache for
easier research and so far we have
classical quest strategies
uh some that some strategies that come
from paper that i will describe
just later and a lot of examples to uh
introduce the active learning if you do
not know the domain and want to know
more
so let's go a bit about the interface
it's very close to
uh the cyclic long one because actually
we discussed with people from cyclic
long which are specialists in terms of
python architecture so you have a base
query sampler
that has a method fit and select sample
and from that we derive
two use cases uh if you're using a score
that is
uh for all the samples uh you can use a
scott query sampler and
that's how we call uncertainty methods
if you want a clustering-based approach
like the one i described that runs the
k-means and find the uh
the sample closest to the centroid you
can use a case android sampler
interface and on the top right you see
the kind of example we provide that is
comparing
all samples on the toy data set but you
can do that on one of your experiments
if you want
and now a bit of code
small warning it's not final until the
end
until version 1.0 so if you want to
contribute if you think that we're doing
things good or bad please tell us
uh it starts like a classical experiment
so we have the train
a small configure dictionary will come
to it afterwards
we have a classifier we have a query
sampler in that case the margin and we
have some backside we want to uh
to explore the first thing to do
is to instantiate a replay cache
so we have the reason cache that allows
you to run an experiment once
and cache the data accordingly but it
clears them afterwards so that that
doesn't take too much disk space
or you have the replay that stores
everything and allows you to rerun an
experiment
first thing to do is uh to declare a
variable that's
the values that will be cached after
each loop
of active learning here we take selected
which is the
which are the indices of the selected
samples
we declare our main loop uh here we have
a cachita util that will
go through the batch sizes and that will
uh provide
automatically the method uh the value of
the previous
loop that we have put here uh
for the selected variable so the
advantage of this is that if you ask for
a value that was
a three iteration before this will be
kept in memory to avoid
uh the reading and writing to this too
after
classic active learning stuff we fit the
classifier
we want to store the accuracy again we
provide the util for that it will be
stored in a
in sqlite database then we fit the
sampler
and we update the value in selected by
uh using the previously selected
indices with the new ones and what
happened is that all of that will be
cached
and we will be able to use it to compute
metrics
afterwards so if you have forgotten to
put a metric
in your loop here we didn't put any you
can still compute it afterwards it will
be done
thanks to the data that has been cached
during the
experiment obviously there it will be
read completely from disk
so now let's see what has been saved by
cardinal so on the left you see what is
on the disk we have a nice tree so
with the cache the method uh which is
margin
and for each iteration we have the
selected uh values that are stored on
disk
and on the right you see the database
that we explore using the very good
python package data set that allows you
to explore sqlite database easily
and you can see if we take the table
accuracy that we have saved all the
accuracy along
the experiment and that allows you to
actually
perform several experiments in parallel
because the database will handle the
concurrent access
so let's talk a bit about
reproducibility like i told you we
provide the method that has been
presented by zlanov
this query strategy uses uncertainty to
pre-select for example 10 times the num
the the
the batch size that we want to select so
we first use uncertainty which is
not costly and then on 10 times this
batch size
we run a k-means and as usual we take
the
sample closest to the centroid so this
is method that scale well
and that has good performances actually
what we've done is that we've reproduced
the results and provide them in cardinal
so you can see on the amnes data sets
that we managed to reproduce the results
even though the confidence intervals are
bigger than in the original paper we
reached the same conclusion which is
that the proposed method is better
than uncertainty or random
onsite then they do not reach a clear
conclusion
uh we did not reach it yet uh we see
that uncertainty is better than random
actually the other methods are competing
they have a similar result uh one thing
that we note is that
we have um an accuracy that is much
better
uh than the uh the one in the paper and
that may be due to the number of epochs
or
uh parameters that are not specified in
the paper so we do not have uh
an answer yet from zenov because we are
in the
process of releasing it into cardinal
but we expect to have
an answer as soon as possible that
brings me to my conclusion
so active learning is still an active
field of research
because we are still acquiring a lot of
data in a lot of different use cases
and the experiments that are provided
are often hard to interpret and to
reproduce
that's why we propose some metrics we
still have no
odd conclusion because we need to test
them on a wider range of use cases
so we have a preliminary results but we
are still working on it
and we are doing that using cardinal
that we have made
available to the whole community and we
have big ambition we want to
revolutionize active learning
uh of course like everybody but uh for
now we convey only minimum functionality
so if you want to contribute please
reach out
and obviously if you want to contribute
to that from the inside of that i could
not hesitate
we are hiring thank you for your
attention i will now answer your
question